scientists now think whether an animal  is predator or prey may drive the  evolution of its pupil prey species such  as goats and horses have horizontal  pupils while predators that ambush their  victims have vertical slits having eyes  on the sides of their heads and  horizontal pupils give prey animals a  panoramic view well-suited to spotting  predators the horizontal pupil enables  this wide view because it allows more  light to enter the eye from in front and  behind however when a horse or goat is  grazing it moves its head up and down  which could turn the eye vertical and  eliminate the benefits of the horizontal  pupil so the animals have evolved to  rotate their eyes to keep the pupil  parallel to the ground  an ability known as Psychlo Bergeon s'